bbbb des réunions professionnelles nuits
saint georges et ensuite seulement gérer
à la marche des candidats dijon qui sera
deuxième 12 points d'avance est plus que
jamais en marche guidée par hisser son
équipe ont concocté un programme d'entre
deux tours bien chargé dans cette
circonscription même si les jeux ne sont
pas encore faits la partie semble bien
engagée pour l'ex directeur de cabinet
de françois patriat
mais le candidat de la république en
marche ne souhaite pas pour autant
baisser la garde
donnons du sens à notre action je vois
des entreprises des élus des
associations
j'espère aller dans une maison de
retraite enfin voir des voir tout ce qui
fait le quotidien de nos france essayer
de mieux les comprendre et mieux les
portes et demain à l'assemblée nationale
pour autant que je souhaite bien
évidemment pour voter sauf qu'en cinq
minutes on joue l'avenir de notre pays
boos sans gants pour le tandem paulo
souvenons l'abstention c'est sur elle à
cause de leur mauvais résultats d une
abstention dans leur propre camp le
candidat de droite a perdu dimanche près
de 5000 voix par rapport au score de
françois fillon à la présidentielle
alors que didier parisse lui hatem il
voit de mieux qu emmanuel macron
cependant hubert poullot n'entend pas
baisser les bras
remobiliser les gens leur faire
comprendre que aujourd'hui notre
république j'emploie les termes qui sont
fort notre république est en danger
on ne peut pas avoir dans une démocratie
comme la france une pensée unique
ce n'est pas possible il faut que les
différentes familles politiques soient
représentées pour ouvrir le débat en
débattre amendé et c'est dans ce sens
qu'on peut construire un pays libre
tractage une interview rencontres et
réunions publiques
les candidats sont maintenant dans la
dernière ligne droite et multiplient
leur présence sur le terrain reste à
savoir si cela rome mobilisera
l'électorat